quiero hacer un regalo muy original para
el cumpleaños de mi hermano voy a poner
una frase de felicitación y la cortar en
piezas como si fuera un rompecabezas
pero no de los que tienen piezas como
estas será un rompecabezas geométrico la
verdad todavía no sé muy bien cómo
hacerlo vamos a averiguarlo para empezar
hay que determinar qué figura usaremos
si elegimos triángulos al ponerlos uno
tras otro se vería algo así wow
está increíble ya me lo imagino de
colores y todo decorado aunque se ven
como dientes o algo así y no sé si le
guste eso acomodamos los triángulos de
diferente manera
ahora juntemos las esquinas ya no
parecen dientes este diseño me gusta
pero seguro que encontraremos más
intentamos con el cuadrado pongamos uno
después otro y otro y uno más pues las
piezas quedarían bastante bien aunque se
parece un poco a los rompecabezas
normales
sigamos probando figuras ahora el
pentágono vamos a poner muchos juntos se
ven bien coloquemos otra fila
los tendremos que poner de cabeza ahora
otra hilera espera quedan espacios en
forma de triángulo entre los pentágonos
no funciona para el rompecabezas porque
no pueden quedar espacios vacíos
tendremos que probar con otra figura
siguen los hexágonos pongamos uno aquí
otro a un lado no mejor contemos dos
lados diagonales así quedan bien
agreguemos uno abajo uno al lado uno
arriba igual quedan perfectamente con
razón las abejas escogieron los
hexágonos para hacer sus panales no
dejan ningún hueco por ningún lado y
amon han muy bien seguro que los
heptagon os van a quedar geniales
probemos vamos a poner uno aquí
otro no quedan muy bien los pondremos al
lado y otros en fila luego tomamos otra
fila y la ponemos encima
no queda muy bien la pondremos de cabeza
qué increíble se formó una estrella
justo en medio de cuatro octágonos y si
ponemos otra hilera igual tenemos una
fila de rombos y otra de estrellas se ve
tan bonito pero no nos sirve para el
rompecabezas por esos espacios que hay
probemos con los octágonos a ver qué
sorpresas nos tienen dibujemos un
octágono aquí si podemos poner varios
juntos en la fila sin dejar espacios
ahora pongamos otra fila encima también
hay espacios en forma de rombo aunque no
se ve nada mal tampoco nos funciona
retomaré las figuras con las que no
quedan espacios recuerda que fueron el
triángulo el cuadrado y el hexágono este
tipo de organización geométrica se llama
de ese lado regular y puede formarse con
varias figuras siempre y cuando sea la
misma la que se repite pero porque las
demás figuras regulares que vimos no
pueden formarse así sin dejar espacios
entre sí
he estado pensando y es debido a los
ángulos que tienen un triángulo
equilátero tiene 60 grados en cada uno
de sus ángulos si juntamos seis
triángulos por la esquina
tendremos 60 por 6 es decir 360 grados
para completar un giro por eso los
podemos acomodar también la otra figura
que se acomodó bien es el cuadrado y
este tiene ángulos rectos en cada
esquina o sea ángulos de 90 grados
por lo tanto cuatro veces 90 también nos
da 360 grados de un giro completo y por
último tenemos el hexágono con ángulos
internos de 120 grados con tres de estos
ángulos tenemos 360 el heptagon o tiene
128 puntos 5 grados y no nos daría los
360 exactos el octágono tiene 135 grados
en cada ángulo interno así que tampoco
nos da una suma exacta de 360
la siguiente figura que nos podría dar
una suma exacta sería una con 180 grados
de cada lado y esa figura no existe así
que sólo tenemos el triángulo el
cuadrado y el hexágono usar el hexágono
para el rompecabezas puedes jugar con
las otras figuras y rellenar los
espacios para formar mosaicos o tomar
figuras que no sean regulares y
repetirlas
muchas veces solo recuerda si la
formación es con una sola figura será un
test helado regular si usamos varias
serán solo lindos mosaicos